c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
toi
allez juste
là
attention pas du tout la musique est
formidable bien sots harry s
une cata bien si elle saura troisième
énorme après et ainsi s y assister merde
et là ça passe ça brasse jeu
stonehill ko merde voilà vous étiez pas
sur des patins aux pieds sur des
chaussures et conscientiser petits
crampons
on sentait que vous étiez ne sera pas
samedi gambin à l'aise
alors donc il fait 10 degrés sur le
plateau tout ça je vous expliquais un
truc parce que c'est vrai que j'ai je
fais peu de démission comme celle là il
ya un l'une des choses qui facilite le
travail d'animateur sur les prime c'est
les kilomètres de promoteur en vous là
on descend l'escalier conséquent ciel
répétition bien sûr moi je déteste le
promoteur a ri et je voulais pas me
faire ce qui est une erreur j'aurais dû
me rattache à ça et donc c'est vrai en
plus il ya une jeune fille qui est
opératrice panthers s'appelle pam qui
est génial qui fait tout et tous les
trucs mais moi j'arrive pas à lire un
prompteur sa murray dit et donc c'est
vrai qu'il faut agir maintenant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]